Speaker 1: OK, let's move on now to another
example of just I don't know what you want
to call it, just more more delusions.
Many of you, of course, know Fox News host
Tucker Carlson.
He has a highly rated program on Fox News.
He is seen as sort of a thinking man's conservative
by many, which I know is really difficult
to believe.
He did an interview yesterday with a guy named
Jason Whitlock, Jason Whitlock, I believe,
sort of originally.
Yeah.
Sports columnist turned right wing pundit
Jason Whitlock.
He's become a very popular item.
I feel stupid calling him a cultural critic,
but he's become a guy who weighs in on cultural
issues and the right loves it and why they
love it, I don't know.
I suspect maybe it's he has a fan base from
when he was in the sports world eager to listen
to him.
Maybe the fact that he's African-American
makes him useful to the conservative movement,
as we've seen many times before.
For whatever reason, Jason Whitlock has quite
an audience.
He appeared on Tucker Carlson's program with
Tucker Carlson and they were talking about
the left.
And Jason Whitlock says, I think the left
is satanic.
And Tucker Carlson agreed.
This is completely outrageous that this is
considered mainstream right wing political
commentary at this time.
Let's take a look at it together
Speaker 4: and destroying this country.
Speaker 3: What do you think?
I've always wondered this, like, what is the
actual support for the ideas?
Not, you know, do you like Trump or Biden?
But, for example, do you think men can get
pregnant or do you think some races are morally
superior to other races, like the core ideas
of the Democratic Party?
How many Americans actually believe that stuff?
Would you
Speaker 1: guess?
So first of all, the questions are crazy,
right?
Whether men can get pregnant.
Those may be the terms that are being used
in some circles, but it's not really at issue.
Right?
I mean, OK, we can all understand there might
be a trans man who was born biologically female
and thus has the equipment with which they
could get pregnant, but their their gender
identity could be male.
But we're not really talking about whether
biological men can get pregnant.
The idea of the Democratic Party, the idea
that the Democratic Party has as a core belief
that some races are superior to others.
Of course, that's ridiculous.
So even the framing is already crazy, but
it's just crazy upon crazy.
Speaker 4: I don't think five percent of America
believes it, maybe 10 percent.
I don't know, Tucker.
I'm going to say something that difficult
to unpack in this short amount of time.
But it's what I truly believe.
I think a lot of what the left supports is,
say, Tanit, I'm just sorry.
It's it's in direct objection.
Speaker 1: Tucker says, yeah, now he'll agree
more.
But this is political analysis that the beliefs
are satanic to God.
Speaker 4: And the indirect objection to the
Judeo-Christian values that were at the foundation
of this country and those Christian values
are why we made so much progress in terms
of freedom and humanity and the way we treat
everybody.
Yes, it was hard, but our Christian values
compelled us to sacrifice our lives for the
freedoms of other Americans, of slaves and
through the civil rights movement, our Christian
values.
Speaker 1: By the way, that's a civil rights
movement that the right was against, but that's
not mentioned here,
Speaker 4: propelled us to take risks and
fight for equality and the equality of opportunity
for everybody.
I just I see a lot of what's going on here
is I'm just sorry.
I'm a man of faith.
I was raised in the church.
This stuff is satanic.
That that's what's at the foundation of a
lot of this stuff.
Speaker 3: Well, I'm a pretty mild Protestant
personally, but I completely agree with you.
Speaker 1: Even a mild Protestant like Tucker
says this is nothing other than the work of
Satan, especially
Speaker 3: the gender stuff.
When you say you can change your own gender
by wishing it, you're saying your God and
that is satanic.
I completely agree.
Speaker 1: And this is completely and totally
delusional.
And there's a couple other aspects to this.
One is the Satan stuff.
It has kuhnen vibes.
Are they kowtowing or are they signaling to
the Kuhnen people that they are specifically
and noticeably on board with the Satan stuff?
There's like a Salem witch trials vibe to
it, and lots of the stuff they talk about
is is very precisely crafted language like
change your own gender versus you just address
people with the pronouns they prefer.
Sounds much less scary, sounds much less strange,
sounds much less supernatural when you say
that.
The problem is that people like Tucker, to
a degree, Jason Whitlock, they're seen as
thinkers by the right, which right now the
right is completely missing.
Any serious voices?
I mean, who like who is out there right now
to be taken seriously?
Not that we agree with them.
Andrew Sullivan is a guy I have found interesting
for a long time.
Is he even really a right winger, though?
He's like a liberal conservative Catholic
gay guy.
He's disaffected with the right, with the
American right.
He's been disaffected with it since George
W. Bush.
Does he even really count?
Doesn't mean I agree with him on everything
or even much.
But he at least has had interesting things
to say.
But I'm not even sure that he's really even
a right winger.
He certainly has nothing to do with these
people at this point.
You know, people like Ben Shapiro and Dan
Bongino, these are not real thinkers.
There's really a dearth right now.
It's like maybe Neil Ferguson.
And I'm not it's always risky to do this because
I'm not saying I support them or endorse their
beliefs, but I'm just saying there are there
are people who are doing more serious thought
coming to conclusions I disagree with.
But this is just gutter nonsense at its core.
It's a very, very sad state
of affairs.